all right and then let's check in
quickly with Alex who interrupts Alex
who interrupts what's going on today I'm
curious because I saw a video about like
that with the Democrats yoke of
presidential candidates you're asking
who can win like asking about win
ability and it reminded me of the 2016
the during the Republican primary there
are Republicans that were asking the
same thing
mm-hmm and my my question was like like
if it's just about defeating Hillary
Clinton you know the probable nominee
like what is the purpose of the
Republican Party because if it's just
about winning then it's a sport right so
I mean my question is for for Democrats
now what is the purpose of the Democrat
Party well I don't income
I don't think Democrats see defeating
Trump as merely sport to check a win on
you know they get a check on the win
column rather than the lost column I
think that Democrats see that basically
any of the possible candidates would be
an improvement I'm speculating here I
think that if you ask Democratic voters
they would say any of the 20-plus people
running would be better than Trump so
it's not about getting a win for sport
it's that we just think whoever replaces
Trump from the possible candidates is
going to be an improvement okay well my
question still is what is the purpose of
the Democrat Party the Democratic Party
like the Republican Party wants to hold
seats in elected government so that they
can advance their agenda okay what is
their agenda well I mean I don't know
that you need me to list it and includes
a $15 minimum wage it includes
increasing access to health care
includes reducing inequality it includes
green energy I mean it did I you don't
need me to list that that's online but
each party has an agenda which they want
to advance by winning races right okay
so I mean they have all these things
that they want right and
they they're going to achieve it how the
same way Republicans would achieve it by
taking control of the Senate taking
control of the White House and passing
bills okay I mean I get if you're saying
there
their goal is to change the country my
question is how is how is what they want
different they have different policy
priorities than Republicans but like
they both understand how politics works
right you got to win races and then your
people are in power and then they make
decisions right I understand with your
previous call he was asking why aren't
people marching in the streets yeah
asking to like impeach Trump and it's
kind of ironic you were saying oh it's
because they're too employed no that's
not you completely misunderstood what I
said is when you have a system in which
the there is such disproportionate power
and economic stability between the rich
and corporations and the mass the mass
of the workers you put them in a
situation where they cannot afford their
economic situation is so precarious they
cannot afford to even take a day off or
to travel to an urban center to mass
rally or whatever the case I think you
may be misunderstood deliberately or
accidentally what I said okay one I see
it as their they have a job so maybe
that's why they they're not calling for
impeachment yeah all right we disagree
but I appreciate you not interrupting
today you did a really good job
okay thanks yep all right that's it for
Alex that's it for life calls for today
a lot of important stories to get to
right after the break